if you want to see one statistic
that really exposes
the united states
as a growing
dystopian hellscape
of
anti-intellectualism and non-thinking
it is this statistic
in the last three polls
herschel walker is leading rafael
warnock
now if you're wondering who these people
are
i will remind you herschel walker is the
republican senate nominee in georgia
right now that seat is held by raphael
warnock raphael warnock is an
intelligent
thinking
uh nuanced elected official who whether
you agree with him or not on any
individual policy
clearly has the interests of george's
residence uh as his priority
and can engage with others in clear
and productive ways where you understand
what he thinks and you can talk
substantively about issues herschel
walker is a former football player who
can barely speak coherently
can't explain his views about any issue
and is
epitomizing
the worst of the non-thinking maga
movement
and yes in recent polls
walker has taken a lead if we look at
the last three poles in that race
the insider advantage pole has walker
plus three
the emerson pole has walker plus two
and the trafalgar pole has walker plus
one those are the last three polls we
have two of them from august and one
from september
this is a man who cannot express himself
this is a man who cannot
explain
why he believes what he believes on any
issue
and there are enough people in georgia
seemingly willing to vote for him that
he might actually take out incumbent
senator raphael warnock many of you have
written to me and you've said david you
know
it was bad when bush beat gore and it
was bad when trump beat hillary and it
was bad when the country elected
marjorie taylor green and on and on but
there is something i can't put my finger
on
if the country elects walker over
warnock i'm getting the hell out of here
and i don't know that people are
literally meaning that often when people
say i'll move to canada they don't
really mean it it's also really
difficult to move to canada just as a
reminder
this is what we're talking about when we
talk about herschel walker here is
walker asked why he hasn't agreed to
debate warnock
it's a very strange answer
senator raphael warnock wants to debate
you you didn't debate during the
primaries where you walked away with 68
of the republican votes
why would you commit to a debate well
first of all senator warnock has nothing
else to talk about he don't want to talk
about the high gas prices he don't want
to talk about the high groceries i've
told him many times i'm ready to debate
him anytime any day i just want to make
it for the fans not about a political
party or about some media and all these
for the fans these are elected officials
or want to be elected officials
wow
here is the same herschel walker asked
by cnn reporter manu raju should there
be new laws in the wake of the latest
shooting
hey
with cnn
[Music]
i like to see it and everything and
stuff and then famous famously herschel
walker weighing in on his plan for
uh
dealing with shootings through social
media see that is the person willing
that weapon you know kane kia able you
know and uh you know that's the problem
that we have and i said what we need to
do is look into how we can stop those
things you know he talked about doing a
disinformation what about getting a
department that can look at young men
that's looking at are women that are
looking at uh just social media what
about doing that we need a department
looking at young men that's looking at
women that's looking at social media he
is now leading in the three recent polls
this
is scary as hell
scary as hell
let me know what you think will
ultimately happen in that race monday 9
19 is our next one day membership drive
if you've been thinking about getting a
membership but you'd like to get a
massive humiliatingly huge discount
humiliating to me let's be honest i'll
get on my newsletter at davidpakman.com
monday morning you'll get an email
telling you exactly how to take
advantage of this great discount 919 is
the day